was there a moment of thinking like if I
allow myself to experience joy and
gratitude then I'm not going to be able
to be as hard that I'm going to lose
that edge no that's not at all what it
was was um I never felt that my entire
life when you're born in a happy home
and you're born around happy [__] it
kind of comes out I don't laugh my dad
beat the laughter out of me there's not
joy in that [__] that becomes who you
are no matter how much you change you're
scarred it's my life so you gotta teach
yourself how to read and write and also
[__] smile don't forget where I came
from it's who you are you have to undo
that [__] and no one came down and
trained me on how to be happy how to
find peace that's why I'm so glad I
found it through suffering the greater
the suffer the greater the peace I found
but you have to reflect on where you
came from to find final peace and be
able to say wow [__] if you die
in this bed at 40 years old I'm the
happiest [__] in the world
because I did it